[Musique]
l'hôpital notre dame le trafic est dense
dans le stationnement de l'urgence
transformé en espace d'accueil c'est
maintenant sous la tente que les
patients sont triés puis envoyés dans la
zone jaune ou rouge de l'urgence
réaménagé dans le garage des ambulances
il ya des nouveaux problèmes qui se
pointent à chaque jour puis en tentant
de les résoudre et on avance comme ça on
est en situation de crise il faut
pouvoir et il faut être créatif
l'interniste dirige l'unité antique vite
de l'hôpital notre dame les médecins
apprennent depuis quelques semaines que
lors d'une pandémie
la logistique est aussi importante que
la science pour éviter la contagion
il faut revoir tout circuit que le
patient empreinte dans l'hôpital comment
protéger cette infirmière là qui évalue
le patient comment l'orienter au bon
endroit donc cette logistique hhla est
essentielle non seulement pour protéger
tout le monde mais parce que sur le
terrain ça va vite
des travailleurs humanitaires qui ont
combattu l'ebola en afrique de l'ouest
ont conseillé la construction d'un
hôpital à l'intérieur de l'hôpital pour
isoler les malades qui ont la cote vide
on a monté des mules finalement tout
simplement encore place laquelle la même
matière les kits utilisés pour faire les
pancartes électorales qu'on connaît bien
et on a vraiment cloisonné une portion
de l'hôpital
à l'hôpital de verdun l'accueil et le
pré triage ont aussi été réaménagé dans
le stationnement et le garage
ces gens là sont installés dans les
espèces de cliniques qu'on a monté kilic
temporaire pour les codes de risque de
coded et d'un garage ce sol après la
première éclosion de la copie d'ici qui
a affecté 30 patients et 70 employés
verdun a ajouté une étape à l'accueil
tous les patients sont testés avant
d'être hospitalisé toute la structure
blanche que vous voyez c'est ils ont
tous des places séparées isolés et ont
un petit peu de consultation aller au
bout on peut faire les radiographies sur
place
on peut faire un électrocardiogramme
puis les prises de salies et s ont fait
la fac ces patients alors reste là
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait diagnostic il a
fallu réaménager en accéléré l'hôpital
de verdun
c'est une extension de l'hôpital de gros
travaux pour un vieil établissement qui
n'a que des chambres avec plusieurs lits
il faut qu'on prenne des champs
le pass hier outre ou aux patients et en
mettre un soldat ça diminue grandement
notre capacité d'accueil mais segment de
la sécurité
on est en train de construire une annexe
de 36 lits pour éviter que l'urgence ne
déborde
c'est de là qu'est venue l'idée d'avoir
une annexe complémentaires pour avoir le
maximum de champ isolé pour les patients
malgré les nouvelles mesures
l'hôpital de verdun connaît une autre
explosion treize patients ont été
infectés
même s'ils étaient soignés dans une zone
froide jusqu'ici 136 employés ont
contracté la co vide à l'hôpital de
verdun 37 à notre dame dans tous les
établissements du centre sud de montréal
près de 800 employés ont été contaminées
dre vraiment sincèrement remercier tout
le personnel
mm parce qu'ils sont vraiment
exceptionnelles
je pense qu'il faut
faut saluer le courage de ces jeunes ce
qui me touche le plus c'est de voir
beaucoup de gens paient et malgré tout
les gens se présentent les gens font les
soins légende ton épaule dos à la
situation